LaRon Bennett jr. where did you get the
title of your book forced in the glory I
thought that book captured the essence
of what I was trying to say in the sense
that Lincoln from my standpoint was
driven was forced into a glory that he
resisted I think every step of the way
Adam Gauss key one of the of his great
critics during the civil war here in
Washington wrote a paragraph which said
that he was literally whipped into glory
III I thought maybe force would be a
better term for the cover and so I
started on forced into glory
and as again captures my idea and one of
the basic ideas of the book is that
there were all these extraordinary men
and women many of them white in
Washington in 1862 and 63 the American
people generally do not know anything
about any of them Ashley Lyman Trumbull
sakura-chan Chandler Salman Chase all
these people I say and I try to detail
it for 650 pages or so really pushed
Lincoln to glory and I'ma the pen I put
into it
Lincoln himself said I was driven to it
literally driven to it your sub title on
the book is Abraham Lincoln's white
dream what's that mean it means that
contrary to what most people think
Abraham Lincoln's deepest desire was to
deport all black people and create an
all-white nation it sounds like a wild
idea now and it is a while idea but from
about 1850 to until his death he worked
feverishly to try to create deep
plans colonization plans to send black
people either to Africa or to South
Africa South America or to the islands
of the sea no but most people then you
know the story one of his greatest
utterances people quoted all the time
Copeland's great thing we cannot escape
we cannot escape history the last best
hope of the world he said these words in
a State of the Union message on December
the 1st 1862 in which he asked Congress
to pass three constitutional amendments
one to buy the slaves second to declare
free all people who had actually escaped
but the third one his proposed 15th
amendment asked Congress to allocate
money to deport black people to another
place now his most I think it's probably
other than the second inaugural the the
we cannot escape history ending there is
just just just porter everybody knows
nobody talks about the fact that what he
was asking Congress to do was to deport
black people it is one of his deepest
ideas and I make the point also and and
and almost everything I say in here I
take from Lincoln are from documents of
the time it was not just something he
wanted to push black people out he had
an idea of this great giant vacuum sound
black people leaving and white people
from all over the world coming here and
creating this all-white nation as a
matter of fact I say as you know in his
I have a dream speech at Alton Illinois
in in 1858 he called for a Haven a white
haven for free white people everywhere
the world over now these are Lincoln's
work and they're just in thing about
that is that he underlined these four
words free white people everywhere he
underlined this was as I have a dream
speech he was passionately committed to
to to deport in black people and
creating a white nation let me say it
again in extenuation he believed that
that was the only way to solve the race
problem I I found that offensive and
strange but he believed that that was
the only way to solve the race race
problem he said over and over again he
did not believe that black people and
white people could live together in
equality in the United States of America
did you ever think differently about
Abraham Lincoln no really and I tried to
explain in the beginning of the book
first sentence in the book first
sentence in the book says I was a child
in whitest Mississippi reading for my
life when I discovered for the first
time but everything I've been taught
about Abraham Lincoln was a lie now I
imagine I was 10 11 somewhere there
before then apparently I believe that
this disagreed this was the great
Emancipator what happened actually when
I was 10 11 and I'll explain I was one
of these strange children I've read
everything I could put my hand on in any
book in a piece of paper anything I
could find I read and so for some
strange reason in Mississippi in the
thirties I happen to see Abraham
Lincoln's address at Charleston Illinois
on September the 18th 1858 the
lincoln-douglas debate in the
lincoln-douglas debate and I read it and
I was just just absolutely shocked and
from that point on I started to research
in Lincoln and trying to find out
everything I could about him I wasn't
trying to get a degree I wasn't trying
to pass a course as I say in the book I
was trying to say in my life because I
find it difficult to understand how
people could say this man was the
greatest apostle of brother Brotherhood
in the United States of America you say
on page iron 14 not only is Lincoln a
church he is also an industry precisely
precisely
and the key are one of the keys to the
American personality but an industry yes
all over the country now people are
engaged in packaging information on
Lincoln putting together the exhibits on
Lincoln doing this and doing that about
Lincoln it's a whole industry that that
that employs hundreds of people probably
thousands of people and it's important
from that way he's also a religion and
as I indicate in that same shop
Barbara Petric I think her name is said
in in the New York Times before this
book was published that Lincoln is such
a God that the ordinary rules of
evidence don't apply to him and and and
also the third point I think is
important he is one of the keys to
America Americans see themselves in
Lincoln American politicians tend to
measure themselves about Lincoln he is a
secular saint and I know that and I know
and I said that that what I'm proposing
here that we look at Lincoln is painful
painful the whites and to Black's but I
think it's necessary for the health of
this country and for what we've got to
do about completing the task we started
in the Civil War but never finished have
you ever been invited to speak to the
Abraham Lincoln Association or the
Lincoln Forum neither no I have not
I've talked to a number of group of
groups across the country but I've not
been invited by those two groups I have
been honored by some Lincoln
associations before this came out but no
I've not been invited to speak to them
and one of the suggestions I make in
this book I feel strongly about it that
that there ought to be a dialogue
between academic people the Lincoln
establishment as I say and and and and
other people who have a different vision
of Lincoln to back up and then to get
into some this book has been attacked
pretty harshly in some quarters praised
enthusiastically and others but I am NOT
up to this date and late summer early
fall I've not seen a single review which
disagrees with any one of my four major
points the fifth point there go disagree
with I'm not saying that the a review
anywhere which disagrees with my four or
five major points and if I possible I
can make them my first point is that the
Emancipation Proclamation did not free
black people and it's doubtful if it
ever freed anybody anywhere and that
Abraham Lincoln was not the great
Emancipator or the small emancipate or
the medium sized emancipated
that's the first point can I stop and
ask did you say that in fact the
Emancipation Proclamation may have
created another half man slaves is
everyone right thank you thank you
not only did it not free anybody it
enslaved re-enslave more slaves than it
ever freed because Lincoln said in the
document which most people will never
read he said that he was specifically
excluding certain slaves and southern
Illinois southern Louisiana and Eastern
Virginia and elsewhere but these were
the two main categories now now why did
he exclude these slaves in Louisiana
because they would only slaves he could
have freed on January the 1st 1863 the
Union controlled southern Louisiana and
New Orleans the Union control Eastern
Virginia now in January 1st he could
have freed the slaves all you had to do
was just not specifically exclude them
instead of freeing them Abraham Lincoln
unfortunately on January 2 first said
I'm not talking about you this document
you in the same as you were
because though this document never
existed so we have about a hundred
thousand slaves in southern Illinois
southern in Louisiana sorry about that
and 80 thousand or so in eastern
Virginia having some two hundred and
seventy-five thousand slaves in in
Tennessee who were not touched by it all
across the south I give an estimate of
approximately fifty five hundred
thousand slaves who were re-enslaved are
kept in slavery by the Emancipation
Proclamation I want to come back to that
and then as I make my second point and I
won't tell you what there's critics say
in response to this is the second point
today Bram Lincoln was a racist I don't
have any joy and making that but I think
truth is important he who said who used
the n-word habitually who loved donkey
jokes and and and blackface shows who
said in Illinois and elsewhere that he
was opposed to black people voting
sitting on juries in a mare and with
white people and holding office to
Lincoln was a racist three abraham
lincoln wanted to deport black people
and create an all-white nation that's
three for abraham lincoln was and and
this is the controversial point maybe
they were not five for that abraham
lincoln was contrary to what all the
historians say an equivocation
vacillating leader who prolonged the war
delayed emancipation and increased the
number of casualties now there's no
agreement on that but there are the
three points are four points all my
critics agree on what they say and I'll
be very brief about this they say
laronne Bennett said that the
Emancipation Proclamation didn't free
black people and he
a terrible man for disturbing the peace
of the Republic that's the first
sentence the second sentence of course
the Emancipation Proclamation didn't
free black people the 13th amendment
everybody knows that freed black people
aggrieved my first point the second
point they say LaRon Bennett this is a
review says that Abraham Lincoln was a
racist and he's terrible man for saying
that of course he was a racist second
sentence all white people in the 19th
century were racist I disagree with that
and III defend white people in 19th
century I think it's absurd to say that
everybody in the 19th century was was a
racist but that's the defense my point
is they agree with my second point of
course he was a racist
the third point again is the wrong
Bennett says that Abraham Lincoln wanted
to deport black people and create a
white nation sale of course he wanted to
deport black people not because he
disliked them but because he loved them
so much and he didn't think if they'd
ever be treated right in America my
point is in late summer early fall is
that all of the critics I've seen agree
with my basic points I don't know a
reputable historian with a library card
anywhere who maintains that the
Emancipation Proclamation freed black
people I don't believe one exists
anywhere and yet I'm mad they did people
are screaming in Hollywood you say this
it's the truth you were born where in
Mississippi I was born in Clarksdale my
mother was visiting there we were I grew
up in Jackson and I grew up in Jackson
Mississippi what did your dad do my dad
was a chauffeur and my mother was a cook
she was a chef cook in a restaurant
there were two of us in the family and
my sister and I and we growed we grew up
in and in Mississippi during the
thirties and forties when did you leave
in 45 I left to go to college I left to
go to Atlanta to a Morehouse College
where I finished in 1949 and started
working in Atlanta for four five years
on Atlanta daily world and then I went
to LA to Chicago to ebony magazine where
you still are a writer
still a writer yeah at everything I'm
still at Ebony yes I worked as associate
editor and senior at a non executive
editor when you were at Morehouse
College what were they telling you about
Abraham Lincoln and that's an all-black
College it's an all-black College two
things it's a very interesting very
interesting to most enlightened lightin
professors I said of course he didn't
free the slaves of course he was a
racist
some Orthodox professors said well there
were extenuating circumstances and black
professors some some black professors
there were extenuating circumstances the
major point is before not making this
book is people in black institution
didn't talk about Abraham Lincoln that
much and as I said about 1/2 an interest
in point and somebody needs to do a long
as they own it if somebody does not I'll
do it if I'm still here white authors
have written about 16,000 books and
monographs on Abraham Lincoln black
authors have written in the last 135
years maybe two or three maybe four this
is probably possibly the first
full-scale reassessment and study of
Abraham Lincoln but in the last hundred
thirty-five years black authors have
paid very little attention a brand like
a three or four books maybe five
compared it to 60
thousand books and monographs a Basler
and I quote him in my book vastly at an
essay in 1935 Roy Basler Roy Basler he
was it was astonished by that he said
you know what black intellectuals don't
don't don't don't know deal with Lincoln
more and they said perhaps they've not
find a sign to to to emancipate them by
ought to move to follow at any rate the
interesting thing is that in
predominantly black institutions in
black circles apart from few pieces of
poetry here and there Abraham Lincoln
has never been the thing in black
America that he has always been in white
America which suggests to me and this is
speculation but I see it in the book I
surmise that black people know Lincoln
have always known him at a depth beneath
words at any rate they have not felt
that necessary did not felt the need or
the interest to address him the way of
white historians that addressed her if
you'd have had the opportunity what
would you have said to Martin Luther
King when he was standing on the steps
of the Lincoln Memorial giving his I
have a dream speech in 1963 I would said
that you're absolutely right when you
said that you should a check and it came
back insufficient funds because the
Emancipation Proclamation was precisely
that I was said you're absolutely right
to say that the real test now is to get
together and write the Emancipation that
Lincoln didn't write because as I say in
this book Martin Luther King jr. had a
healthy dose of skepticism about what
Iran Lincoln meant and what Abraham to
confed and in his book where do we go
from here
I think he details most of the things I
say in here but says at the end that
were extenuating
stances he believe he can detect some
growth in Lincoln I have problems with
the growth but we're together on the
analysis he was racist and King knew it
King said it and fundamentally I agree
with most of his analysis now if you
just let me put one pin in this this is
painful I've said it and I keep saying
it over not only to white people
I don't know white people for the last
hundred thirty five years every medium
of communication outside the mediums
media we control has said Lincoln was
the great savior the graded Liberator he
freed you in January the first out of
the goodness of his heart and so large
numbers of black people have just
worship Lincoln I mean he's because they
believed that he did what people say he
did and it's painful to say to them and
to my community and other communities he
didn't do it he didn't want to do it he
was completely different man the point
I'm coming to finally if you do let me
go through this scenario on January the
1st a Thursday 1863 here in Washington
slightly after twelve o'clock they had
the New Year's reception in the morning
and slightly after twelve o'clock
secretary Seward and his son took the
document Emancipation Proclamation to to
Lincoln in the Cabinet Room I think it
was and and and I don't know let me tell
you today Lincoln Lincoln took a steel
tip pen and and him he took the pen and
he moved the line where he's supposed to
sign and all of a sudden when he got to
this line Lincoln tells the story when
he got to this line his then starts
shaking so violently that he couldn't
sign it and he and he dropped the pen
don't what's going on here so he took
the pen again still to a pen and he
moved it to the place
and he started the sign of his hand
starts shaking so violently that he
couldn't think he dropped it again and
Mingo was very superstitious he stopped
in all and then he said Abraham Lincoln
is talking then he said very simple
explanation came to me I had been
signing origami know I've been shaking
hands all that morning at the New Year's
resin and my arm was virtually paralyzed
hence he said a very simple explanation
for this phenomenon I think the expect
the explanation is too simple but that's
what he said at any rate he finally was
able to sign the document no my point
the poetry the songs the scholars the
major newspapers the major museum people
tell us that at that moment choirs start
to sing over the Alleghenies and over
Stone Mountain in Georgia and black
people start saying free at last free at
last thank God Almighty I'm free at last
that's pretty it hurts me to say it's
not true hurts me now to say it's not
true but but but but any slave in
Georgia who said free at last
surrounded by Confederate troops on
January 1st 1863 was immediately sent to
heaven
in in slave in Alabama who said that so
I'm trying to say that that that this
poetry I wish it were true it is not
true virtually almost everything we've
been told about Abraham Lincoln in the
last night and 35 years is wrong on each
correcting our needs somebody to have a
long dialogue when you hear that they're
trying to raise about a hundred and
twenty-five million dollars to buy or to
build a library to a REM Lincoln in
Springfield Illinois what's your
reaction
I think we need an equal amount of money
more money in fact let me let me back up
I think we need to research Lincoln's
life I think we need to know everything
we can about him my book complains that
that people don't know anything about
Lincoln even 135 years later I think we
need to know that I think also we need
an equal amount amount of money we need
more money dedicated to the task of
studying the real emancipator's a study
in Charles Sumner and that is Stevens
and window Phillips all white men all
white men all white men they tell me all
everybody was the greatest is then these
men were a hundred years ahead a very
brave Lincoln in terms of their
understanding of democracy and racial
equality in this country now one of the
one of my complaints in that book is
that Elodie I'm coming back to black and
white Americans find about no shoe if
any white Americans know who Lyman
Trumbull was was Lyman Trumbull was a
senator from Illinois in Lincoln's time
he had the traditional problems of many
of the white men of the area of the time
but he was far more advanced in his
understanding of what Liberty required
of him he opposed the Fugitive Slave Act
in Illinois at a time when Abraham
Lincoln was was back in the hunting of
men women and children he defeated
Abraham Lincoln for the Senate and the
reason he defeated Lincoln for the
Senate is because Lincoln was too
conservative on the issue of slavery in
Illinois and in America but the bottom
line lament Rommel came to Washington he
was the author of the first Confiscation
Act which began the Emancipation
Proclamation in August 1861 he was the
author of the second Confiscation Act
which was the most sweeping act of
emancipation passed by Congress
are enacted during Lincoln Stein more
sweeping than the Emancipation
Proclamation and he was one of the
principal authors of the 13th amendment
a hundred years ahead of Lincoln nobody
in Illinois knows Lyman Trumbull deny
that that I'm exaggerating one or two
people knowing but they've had no major
exhibits and in Illinois on Lyme and
trauma we had a hundred exhibits on
Lincoln who didn't believe in equality
who did little or nothing to advance the
abolitionist process why isn't the
cultural structure teaching people
lament rumbles name I'll win the
Phillips or Charles Sumner as you know
almost every poll that's ever taken has
Abraham Lopez number one as you know cuz
you write about in your book and you
don't put this call for him but a lot of
liberal American colleagues professors
think Lincoln was the greatest why white
college professor white collar fair and
and almost all of the major history
professors in this country and I find
that I find that extraordinary because
because until the capture of Atlanta and
the nomination of Journal McClellan on
the Democratic ticket late in 1864 until
late 1864 almost all members of
Lincoln's party thought he was a
disaster as a president and most of them
were looking for some alternative
candidate almost all members of the
Washington power structure at that time
said he like will he liked your
resolution he liked vision and that he
was prolonging the war by his
inadequacies a lament rumbles said he'd
liked the resolution needed in this
great task his secretary
I mean his attorney general Bates said
he like will others said in it at the
time that he was simply a terrible
leader and yet
135 years later almost all the scholars
saves the greatest leader we've ever had
in our country perhaps in the world why
because they have not read the record I
say because there has been for 135 years
one of the biggest attempts in all
history to hide a man and a history and
to make the man entirely different from
what he was and and and why because
Lincoln is a mask for certain
deep-seated problems we blacks and
whites have resisted and refused to deal
with particularly the problem of slavery
the problem of emancipation and and the
problem of black freedom in this country
Lincoln far from being a leader let that
doesn't mean stop and deal with it
Lincoln far from being a leader was
everybody knows him everybody he was a
man on the fence who denounced it
extremists on both sides who talked out
of both sides of his mouth and this is
an ideal that that that that that
appeals to too many people I say in the
book that although people won't tell us
who Lincoln was history knows Lincoln
they know that he was a waffling
equivocating person I quoted a person
and one of the major papers just before
the book was published they say who said
that George Bush and other presidential
candidates who reminded them of Lincoln
why did they remind this columnist of
Lincoln because he waffled because he
talked out of
sighs his mouth and different audiences
history knows Abraham Lincoln and is my
suggestion that many scholars are
defending that image of leadership
what's the isolated cult school the
isolated court school is the tendency am
agent Lincoln biographers to quote take
isolated quotes out of context and use
them without giving us the context or
the setting of the man
for example they they tell us and I
won't name the historian who might and
mine respect on other grounds said that
the December of 1862 State of the Union
message we talked about the last best
hope of the earth was one of the
greatest statements in the history of
the world he does not tell us that
Lincoln was asking Congress to deport
black people so we get in the Peoria
speech Lincoln says you know I love the
Declaration of Independence one of the
great documents of all time one
paragraph two paragraphs later he said I
don't want you to misunderstand me he's
talking to ten or twelve thousand white
people in the law don't want you to
understand me I'm not talking about
equality I'm not talking about making
black people equal I'm not talking about
free and black people in the south but
it's a great document in the abstract
you get this and I I took a whole
chapter because I knew I would have to
do that
I took a whole chapter and detail the
defenses that scholars built into that
work you talk about Benjamin Thomas and
I know I've done so many shows here on
Abraham Lincoln that more often than not
author will say it's the single best
volume best one volume biography of
Abraham Lincoln right number one why did
they say that who was he and why did you
spend a lot of time writing about him
Thomas is one
work is readable came at a time when
people were groping for some new way to
deal with Lincoln if memory serves I
think it came out sometime or 52 of them
that was sometime around there and it
was just immediately elevated to the
best one-volume treatment of Lincoln
available I used it as an example and I
went down the list of all the things
that that Thomas did not tell us honey
read him so it'd be easier for you you
say Lincoln doesn't tell us that Lincoln
did Thomas doesn't tell us that Lincoln
used the n-word he doesn't tell us that
Lincoln loved in-jokes
he doesn't tell us that Lincoln voted
for Jim Crow legislation in the Illinois
legislature he doesn't tell us that
Lincoln said there was a natural
discussed in the minds of nearly all
white people about black and white sex
he doesn't tell us that Lincoln's
support of the Illinois black laws he
doesn't tell us that President Lincoln
personally ordered Union officers to
return runaway slaves to slave masters
he doesn't tell us that President
Clinton tried for quote nearly a year
and a half in his own words to save
slavery in the United States all these
things I say and this is typical a major
bag of his own Lincoln in the last 135
years that the famous Charleston quote
is the stumbling block as I say in the
book the best
Bogg refers will summarize the
Charleston quote and and what is that
and where what was the reason for it in
the Charleston quote and Saturday
September 18th 1858 Lincoln said to
about 10 to 15,000 white people in the
Lincoln Douglas debate that I will say
then that I'm not now now have I ever
been in favor bringing about in any way
the social and political equality of the
white and black race that I'm not now
ever have been in favor making voters of
of Negroes are
Negros naav qualifying them to hold
office not to intermarry with white
people and he goes on and on a full
quote he ends by saying that he's in
favor of white supremacy now this this
is a terrible quote and it's the sort of
litmus test for Lincoln biographers the
best ones will summarize the quote and
will make an excuse for him that one of
the major excuse as you know from Thomas
and others is to say that Douglass was
pushing him and he had to say that to
get elected
other other people say well he had to
say that in order to get elected in 1858
but most biographers do not give the
full quote they certainly don't get it
in context and they certainly do not as
Thomas does not tell us that Lincoln
voted for Jim Crow laws in the Illinois
legislature voted for a white school
system in Illinois as the legislature
said on the platform that he supported
the black laws and lived in Illinois and
never said a word about an Illinois law
that made it a crime for black people to
live in Illinois we don't get into this
in the traditional biographies and my
problem is beyond leakin I raise the
question and it's a question of dialogue
I raise the question of scholarship I
say you can't divorce a man from his
setting like that and write a biography
on him I say if you don't tell us about
the Jim Crow laws he supported and the
fact that he supported the haunting of
men women and children in the Fugitive
Slave Law if you don't tell us these
things I think we have to reevaluate
what we doing in scholarship but I
mentioned earlier the Abraham Lincoln
Association which meets in Springfield
the Lincoln forum which meets up in
Gettysburg every year has speakers and
they've never invited you to speak if
they did would you walk into that group
give the same thesis that you do in your
book I would walk in that group and give
the same thesis with one exception an
exception I don't believe in lynching
parties and if they want to arrange 15
people on a platform and they said now
you speak and now these 15 people are
gonna let you I don't believe in that
but if they want me to make a speech
I'll make it but one scholar one vote
the way they generally do it and that's
another one of the techniques they've
they will ask there's a 15 20 people to
come in and you speak and then 15 to 20
people to speak I will speak one scholar
one vote and will be to be to be
delighted to to speak and I I think we
need this kind of dialogue but but but
again back to a small problem here I I
did and and you know I've been this road
before in February 1968 I wrote a small
essay in Ebony call was Abraham Lincoln
a white supremacist this distant
explosions everywhere people said the
Republic is in danger I mean that that
just it Smurfs worse than this time okay
then people say well you know he makes
some good points we ought to reevaluate
Lincoln and that number of people said
that but the reevaluation did not come
that si has been out there for some 32
years no real response to it
one of the ways they the academic
authorities respond to me is they put it
as one of the major books on 676 page in
the footnotes and not in the book not
deal with Lincoln and racism but they're
saying the footnotes all their own
Bennett's say that's weird on small
small tight and then they will go on we
still have had a dialogue on this in the
country without being provocative I
think it's important to the truth of
white people and black people for us to
know what was done and was not done
and to certainly know about the black
and white men men and women who tried to
emancipate all of us if Steven a Douglas
was elected president in 1860 what do
you think would have happened unlike
what happened with Abraham Lincoln
getting elected for black people the
first the first case and I'm asked you
that's your question I think the
abolition is that driven the self mad
and they were not going to take Stephen
Douglas but that that's my first
question first answer the second one if
they had I think he would have tried to
create a compromise extending the
modifying is the earlier compromise and
I don't think it would have would have
worked I think it had gone beyond that
point at that time and I don't think
that was in a solution that the
southerners would have approved of I say
in my book and III believe it's true
when develop said it first
that fugitive slaves and abolitionists
and the threat of insurrections had
driven southerners mad then that they in
essence they committed suicide Lincoln
in his inaugural address said that he
would have personally backed a 13th
amendment which had already been passed
which would have guaranteed slavery
forever in the United States of America
the self refused accepted another
question in that area and I appreciate
your question iiiiii
ideal I asked myself the question
Lincoln was a compromise candidate again
going back to leadership he was not
elected because he was a flamin antastic
slaver advic he was that he's elected
because he was less of a anti-slavery
advocate and Seward and Selma chase
question is what would have happened if
suet and and and chase have been elected
president
my view is that emancipation would have
come sooner and in a better context than
it did under Abraham Lincoln on the both
of them I think you would have pretty
much the same thing I think they would
have been riff drawls but I don't think
chase and Seward would have gone so far
in a piece in the south in the border
states and I think this comes to my
theory leadership which is real if
Lincoln had not spent two years of peas
and Kentucky if he had mobilized 400,000
black soldiers
and issued the Emancipation order given
the soldiers freedom I think the civil
war would have been over two years three
years at most and I will say again on
this leadership issue and then I'm
through with it I don't understand the
historians who say his great leadership
if fret if Franklin Delano Roosevelt had
conducted World War two as disastrously
as Abraham Lincoln conducted the Civil
War in the first two years America would
be a German Protectorate today
how many years have you been in Chicago
about 47
how big is evany magazine biggest black
magazine in the world about 2 million
subscribers about 10 million readers of
all every month and this book was
published by Johnson publishing right
John Johnson yes did you try to get it
published anywhere else no I did not
Dez Johnson published books all time no
he publishes books by authors internal
books by authors primarily we published
several books outside but primarily
books by authors people who work at
Johnson publishing company who have
worked at Johnson publish government has
your book been reviewed by the
Washington Post to the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal it has not to
this date been reviewed by the
Washington Post in New York Times or
some other journals we can name it has
been reviewed by a number of major
journals in this country and and as
received as I say I think enthusiastic
reviews from radio people and television
people when did you first think about
doing a book about well it's a
disagreement in my family about that I
say seven years my wife says I've been
doing it for ten or twelve years we
split on ten years maybe what I started
to do as I mentioned I did the essay in
February 1968 and and and it it was not
being circulated anywhere either young
historian called me from University of
Illinois in Urbana say I can't find this
in anywhere it's not in the index so
based on the fact that it was not being
circulated I said you know 10 to 12
years ago seven years ago I think I'll
create a book of essays and put the
Lincoln essays in it I have another
mother essays that I want to put in it
well as I worked on it I said well you
know as an author says maybe you know it
needs a little updating
a year or two later three or four
hundred pages I say well it has to be a
book and so it evolved into that and
let's say 10 years maybe 7 or 12 years
but I've been working on it that time
and and and and I say and and and I hope
you let me say immodestly okay yes I I
worked on this book nights and weekends
for 10 years or so after my day job I
didn't that is that you couldn't do this
at my age I worked 14 hours or so at my
day job and then I would go home and I'd
work at night and then I'd work all
weekend people thought I was crazy and
but I just I just did it year after year
and I I did not receive I had no
graduate assistants books like these
generally done with the army of graduate
assistants I had no graduates assistants
and I didn't get in I didn't get a grant
from from a foundation I did it 10 10
years on my own and people that you know
feel sorry for you and that people of
course are you crazy but it's one of the
most exciting 10 years I've spent
because what I had to do is to I had to
learn how to see again I had to create
new concepts for fiction for trying to
understand Lincoln because the dominant
concepts would have left led me into
error so all this time I was involved in
trying to see you again learning how to
see again and in creating new concepts
for containing the phenomenon that I
think we need a new perspective on how
many copies did you print I don't I
don't I don't remember I know B in the
second printing but I don't I don't
remember said like 30,000 reverse no it
wasn't that many I don't mean oh no
what's been the reaction among black
people to this the reaction has been
tremendous
it's 650 pages footnotes it's not the
kind of book you expect people who walk
down the streets reading but I walk down
the streets and then like people say
thank you for doing the book thank you
for this and I've gotten more response
on this book in the black community and
I've ever gotten and I have another book
before the Mayflower which is one of the
widest circulated black history books
ever but that is response to this has
been electric and I've been very humble
by it this is a bit convoluted let me
try to walk through this if white people
both you know you hear both Republicans
and Democrats liberals and conservatives
putting their arms around Abraham
Lincoln if they think he did a good
thing and they are supporting him
because they think he freed the slaves
what advantage is it to this discussion
if in the end you're successful and
pulling the rug out from under that all
right I'm asked that question the number
ways and just a good question I
appreciate it
the first the first my first response
without getting up on a high horse but
my first response always is that I think
the truth is his own defense
there's absolutely necessary my second
response is to whites and blacks is this
warm comforting symbol who gives out
freedom on the January 1st 1863 my
second response is that that you can't
lie your way to freedom
you can't allow your way to freedom I
can't do it you can't lie your way to
rainbow nation my third response and I
said in the book people who say that are
too late I won't name a presidential
candidate and by this name but but the
people who say that in general know
who Abraham Lincoln is he is they know
he was not John Brown they know he was
not window Phillips they know he was not
a major advocate of liberation they know
in German what this is what most people
know about Lincoln that they he did it
reluctantly he did it to save the Union
that's that's that's the Lincoln that
that these people worship what does that
saying that you don't fight for freedom
if it if it causes problems they know
the Lincoln they're worshiping they
don't want to know John Brown they don't
want to know when the Philip they don't
even want to know Lyman Trumbull
and I'm saying that that we ought to
teach young white children one the
Philips name who said and and and 94
years before King a hundred and thirty
three years before Mandela that he
wanted to create a rainbow nation
composed of the learners and the
ignorant the old and the young the black
and the white pagan Christian Jew all in
one great procession marching toward a
rainbow land he said that a hundred
years ago that ought to be taught if
we're going to overcome the madness
we're going through in this in this
country we need to know white people in
this country going back to Abigail Adams
who really were in favor of the
liberation of black people we need no
need to know black people like Harriet
Tubman and Frederick Douglass etc again
my facts may not be right on the money
but a couple of weeks ago President
Clinton stood in front of the Anderson
cottage out here at the old soldiers
home 750,000 dollars to repair it I
think he mentioned that it was in this
cottage that Abraham Lincoln wrote a lot
of the Emancipation Proclamation
implying that's very positive very good
kind of connect that to want to ask you
whether is Bill Clinton as they said
several years ago the first black
American
president give me two seconds
I've got hope that we come to this first
point the dedication of this Cottage Inn
in the summer and I read newspapers all
across this country almost all of them
Rome
almost all of them totally Rome the big
American newspaper the paper of record
said that it was in the soldiers home
where that Abraham Lincoln drafted the
Emancipation Proclamation he did no such
thing
did no such thing another major American
newspaper no just let me read this I've
brought it to read and won't name the
newspaper said it was at the cottage in
1862 that Lincoln wrote the final draft
of the Emancipation Proclamation issued
january 1st 1863 the Proclamation freed
slaves and Confederate territory
controlled by Union forces not about
five sincere sentences here and there's
six major errors in the Justice pots
this is a major American newspaper in
the first page plays what he he did not
write the second draft of the VATS
efficient proclamation that Cod is what
he wrote there and he did write it he
wrote he made notes there for the
preliminary Proclamation now this is
2,000 American media don't know the
difference between the preliminary
Proclamation and Emancipation
Proclamation the other point was that
document on September the 22nd 1862 the
Emancipation Proclamation was drafted in
the White House on December 31st 1862
but I call your attention to the
sentence and a major newspaper which
said the Proclamation freed slaves and
Confederate territory controlled by
Union forces it did the precise opposite
Lincoln freed slaves and Confederate
territory controlled by Confederate
troops
he left them in slavery in Confederate
or a territory controlled by Union
forces so what about the other half of
that Bill Clinton I I think his
appointment policy is it's been
extraordinary and it's an indication of
of what we should expect from a
president and points in the direction
that we ought to go in terms of trying
to create a rainbow nation Lincoln was
not going in that direction at all and
again here's an indication of a
direction we need to go in in order to
create the rainbow nation that that was
dream that hasn't been lived but now
he's you know he was part of that symbol
of endorsing the Abraham Lincoln thing
in the whole you know standing for the
cottage and that doesn't bother you I
mean what is there I mean all these
presidents both sides all say great
things about Abraham Lincoln but you're
basically saying it's all a lie goodness
I'm saying a fact fact fact all the
major newspapers in America I can name
him said that he wrote the draft of the
Declaration I mean of the Emancipation
Proclamation that guy he did not do it
and this indicates one to me and I come
back to your question that the
misinterpretation and misunderstanding
of Lincoln on this issue has reached a
level of a national scandal when all of
the newspapers put out this
misinformation the second second point
it doesn't bother me even scholars it
doesn't bother me 500,000 phd's swearing
that Lincoln wrote the Emancipation
Proclamation and that in that thing will
not change the fact that he did not do
it the facts are against the theory and
it's the duty of all Americans to begin
now to deal with the facts our guest has
been LaRon Bennett jr. this is what the
book looks like forced in the glory
Abraham Lincoln's white dream
thank you very much thank you delighted
to be